foreign
let's talk about Cold War II I was
actually going to segue to
your thinking and observations of
the not mutually exclusive
combination of maybe conditions that
have been set over the last five to ten
or more years that are now
leading to
certain types of inertia in terms of
Trends converging trends that may or may
not be avoidable then there's a lot of
wiggle room with independent actors and
and so on as we've discussed but
I've I've already described Cold War II
I believe correct me if I'm wrong as uh
China senior partner Russia Junior
partner right in contrast to Cold War
one if you were
placing bets on likely
events or developments over the the next
handful of years
what would you put out as perhaps some
reasonably probable scenarios that we'll
see develop
the cliche quotes often ascribe to Mark
Twain is that history doesn't repeat
itself but it Rhymes but he never said
that
Twain never used those words that's a
made-up quote what Twain actually said
back in the 1870s was that
history was a bit like a kaleidoscope
and as you turned it
certain patterns could repeat themselves
so let's think about this as a
kaleidoscope you'll remember those
things we had as kids where you kind of
stick to your eyes like that's
psychedelic what happens if I turn oh
that's also psychedelic but different
Cold War One
had certain common features with Cold
War II and and there were certain very
important differences so we shouldn't
expect things to play out exactly the
same
on the other hand it's clear that we
have an ideological rivalry between the
United States and the People's Republic
of China there is clearly a
technological race going on
there is also a geopolitical dimension
to this conventional territorial
Dimension and and this is a point Graham
Allison made in his book destined for
war there's some probability that they
end up in a hot War because what's a
cold war George Orwell coined the phrase
to to mean a piece that is no peace it
is something that has latent the
possibility of an actual Hot War and I
think the United States and China have
been in this kind of cold war situation
for at least four years maybe longer I
think the Chinese would probably say
longer but we didn't notice we didn't
notice the beginning of Cold War one
either
when Orwell talks about Cold War in 1945
and Churchill in 1946 talked about an
iron curtain most Americans were no no
no the Stalin's been our Ally in World
War II
you're just warmongering and um it took
until 1950 when there was a hot war in
Korea for most Americans to say ah maybe
they're right I mean Canon wasn't
immediately hailed as a prophet when he
talks about containment
the thing about cold Wars is that by and
large people in the west don't really
notice their beginning and take a while
to understand the scale of the challenge
so we're at that early Cold War stage I
think that's a good analogy that works
well and also this war in Ukraine is
like the Korean War it's the first Hot
War of Cold War II and it makes you kind
of get that you're in a cold war
as in Cold War One the hot War happens
in a slightly unexpected location the
hot war that kicked off Cold War one was
Korea
and the US hadn't really been paying
very close attention to Korea when that
that kicked off
so if you take this kind of approach and
recognize that there are similarities
except that instead of a nuclear arms
race we're in an AI race and a Quantum
Computing race
if you recognize the difference which is
there's much more economic
interpenetration between the US and
China than the ever Wars between the US
and the Soviet Union
you're then in a position to start
hazarding guesses about what happens
next
which is what you asked me to do and
these are are very difficult things to
get right and and I often think that if
one makes a right prediction it's more
luck that it turns out to be right than
judgment because this is a complex
system of enormous complexity
so when we try to say anything about
global politics we're we're really
engaged in in an exercise beyond our
human brains but let me have a go
right now the US and China are on
collision course over Taiwan and Taiwan
is to This Cold War what Cuba was to the
last Cold War it's the flash point it's
an island in close proximity to one of
the players
then it was close to the U.S this time
it's close to China
it's an island which seems to be worth
more than its territorial size would
suggest actually taiwan's more important
than Cuba ever was because Taiwan is
where 92 percent of the most
sophisticated semiconductors in the
world are manufactured by tsmc
and so in some ways the potential for a
crisis over Taiwan is higher than the
potential ever was for a crisis over
Cuba so I think what happens next is
that we end up with a showdown over over
Taiwan at some point in the next few
years could be in 2024 when there's an
election scheduled in Taiwan
and it would also make sense to do it
then from a Chinese point of view
because who knows who will be president
in 2025 but probably not somebody as
completely
incompetent as Joe Biden so my sense is
that the crisis is not far away even
although the Chinese don't look terribly
ready for a full-blown Invasion and
that's the thing that that I'll be
watching most closely in the coming
years the other thing to remember is and
this again is is in the nature of a
guess that
a characteristic feature of Cold War one
was that crises would happen in multiple
locations at roughly the same kind of
time so the Middle East always mattered
and it was the place where things would
periodically blow up I think the Middle
East is about to blow up again
because the Iranian regime clearly has
an incentive to get into a war because
when it's at War it can Slaughter
domestic opposition with much greater
ease so I'm afraid that we're probably
going to see a middle eastern crisis
even before Taiwan blows up and what
worries me the most Tim is that the
lesson of Cold War one is that we only
narrowly avoided World War III as I said
already
so if we're in this kind of a scenario
where there are crises in Eastern Europe
potentially in the Middle East
potentially in the Far East
I think just keeping this a cold war
will be quite a challenge that will be a
good outcome if we just say hmm that was
Cold War II and it'll be a great outcome
if it ends the same way as Cold War one
with peaceful victory for the west but
there is no guarantee at this point that
Cold War II stays cold and there is no
guarantee at this point that the United
States and its Allies win and that's the
real lesson of Cold War one it was not
inevitable that it stayed cold and it
was not inevitable that we won